Carrie Fisher's daughter played a much bigger
role in The Rise of Skywalker than you might
think.
After Fisher suddenly passed away from a heart
attack in December 2016, director J.J. Abrams
and the team behind The Rise of Skywalker
were left with a unique challenge: how could
they incorporate Fisher's iconic character
General Leia Organa without the actress?
Through some clever CGI tricks and a performer
capable of following in Fisher's footsteps,
the impossible became possible.
Unbeknownst to most, Billie Lourd, who appeared
in The Force Awakens and The Rise of Skywalker
as junior communications coordinator Lieutenant
Kaydel Ko Connix, also made an appearance
in the final film of the Skywalker Saga as
a young Leia during a crucial scene where
the princess-turned-general trained in the
ways of the Force.
In an interview with Yahoo!, visual effects
supervisor Patrick Tubach confirmed that while
Mark Hamill went through a de-aging process
to look like a younger Luke Skywalker, Lourd
stepped in to play Leia.
Rumors swirled for months that Lourd, whose
Lieutenant Connix sports Leia's signature
buns during her appearances on screen, would
be playing a young Leia at some point during
The Rise of Skywalker.
Now, Tubach has confirmed those theories.
Though Lourd's face isn't actually used in
the final product it's a CGI rendering of
what Fisher looked like in her youth everything
else of her physical form is.
He said:
"Billie was playing her mother.
It was a poignant thing, and something that
nobody took lightly that she was willing to
stand in for her mom [...] It was an emotional
thing for everybody to see her in that position.
It felt great for us, too.
If you're going to have someone play [Fisher's]
part, it's great that it's [Billie] because
there are a lot of similarities between them
that we were able to draw from.
The real challenge was just making the Leia
footage we had to work with fit in that scene."
VFX supervisor Roger Guyett also told Yahoo:
"What you see is what we developed.
The idea was to provide this great surprise
where they take the helmets off, and you see
Luke and Leia's younger faces.
We scoured outtakes from the original movies,
and we took some pieces and then had to try
and figure out the technical aspect of putting
that shot together."
Going forward, whether or not Leia appears
in any future Star Wars projects will be entirely
up to the young actress.
As Guyett noted:
"The truth is that Carrie was a friend of
J.J. and Billie is a friend of J.J.
They talked a lot about that, and I think
the heart of it is the utmost respect for
Carrie and her memory and her performance."
It couldn't have been easy for Lourd, who
lost both her beloved mother and her grandmother,
Debbie Reynolds, before 2016 came to an end,
to step in and play her mother.
In the build-up to The Rise of Skywalker,
Lourd even addressed the legacy of both her
mother and Leia by penning a deeply emotional
essay for TIME Magazine where she discussed
the good and bad impact that Princess Leia
had on her life.
Initially, Lourd was confused and often irritated
by her mother's fame, but eventually, she
came around.
She wrote:
"I realized then that Leia is more than just
a character.
She's a feeling.
She is strength.
She is grace.
She is wit.
She is femininity at its finest.
She knows what she wants, and she gets it.
She doesn't need anyone to defend her, because
she defends herself.
And no one could have played her like my mother.
Princess Leia is Carrie Fisher.
Carrie Fisher is Princess Leia.
The two go hand in hand."
Lourd then concluded the essay by saying:
"I grew up with three parents: a mom, a dad,
and Princess Leia.
Initially, Princess Leia was kind of like
my stepmom.
Now she's my guardian angel.
And I'm her keeper."
Regardless of whether Lourd takes on the role
of Leia in a future Star Wars film, she's
got an undoubtedly bright future ahead of
her.
After gaining fame and acclaim thanks to her
various roles on Ryan Murphy's anthology series
American Horror Story, Lourd made her mark
on the big screen in Olivia Wilde's directorial
debut Booksmart, playing the absurd, scene-stealing
character Gigi.
If Lourd chooses to retire her mother's signature
character after The Rise of Skywalker, it's
a comforting relief for many fans to get even
a brief glimpse of this beloved character.
And in the end, nobody else could have played
Leia quite like Lourd.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.